the Bengals were very very lucky that
Prince saw our song Hero takes a fall
he'd seen the video and then Prince
started to show up at her concerts there
was a venue in Hollywood called The
Palace and it was a place we played
quite frequently on one of those
occasions there was all this whispering
in the Halls when we were at soundcheck
word was that Prince was going to come
see our performance that night but it
gets even better because we get to the
moment in the set where we're playing
hero takes have fallen sure enough I
look over to the side and Prince is
coming out onto the stage already
shredding on guitar and I was like
everyone in the place hypnotized by the
magic that was happening before our eyes
I mean I never before or since have I
ever been witness to someone's
otherworldly guitar playing it was so
crazy great
foreign